はい それからもうどんどん今日のテーマに入っていきます
世界の価値観 皆 何をしてどのように生きれば幸福になるのか
成功したことになるのかと真面目に考えるんです
これ 真面目に考えてるでしょ？どうすればいいか
どうすればいいか どうすれば金儲けになるのか
どうすればもう豊かになるのかとかいうことは
誰でも真剣に考えているんです
仏教もこれに答えを出そうとするんです
我々はどのように生きていれば幸福で幸せになるのかという
人間必死で探してるんですよ
お釈迦様もそれに答えようとしているんです
だから 生きる目的はあるかないかっていうことは
もうあんまり気にする問題じゃないんですよ
生きる目的がなく生きているんだから
だったら幸福で楽しく成功して生きていきたいんですよ
そこ すごい現実的な人間の問題なんです
敗者さん 敗者っていうのは負けの負けた人の思考ではなくて
誰でもそれぐらいは思います
どうすればもっとうまくいくのかということは誰にでもあります
それは仏教でもお釈迦様が大変なことを喋っている間で
合間でそういうところを教えてはいるんです
どうすれば成功して幸福で生きているのかというアドバイスはいくらでもあります
しかし 世間は命とは 生きるとは何かという問題に答えを見つけてないんです
どうすれば幸福に生きていられるのかと思うんだけど
生きるということは何なのかとはわかってないんです
これはね 車っていうのは
一度も見たことがない人は
どうすれば無事 事故でなんて言いますか
無違反で無事故で運転できるのかと考えることと同じなんですよ
もういい加減にしろよと
車を見たこともないんだからね
それは考えることできるのは
車はよく知っていて 見たこともある
車ってこんなものやと知ってる人なんです
その知ってる人はどうすればうまく運転できるのかといえば
あんた教習所に行きなさいと
それで話は終わるんです
免許取りなさいと それからもう毎日のように運転してみなさいと
どんどんうまくいきますよと
いうことは答えはっきりしますよ
しかし どう生きれば幸福になるのかという人が
そんなことを考える前に
生きるっていうことは何なのかと発見していないと
いい加減な答えになるんです
だから世の中も仏教も
どうすれば幸福になるのかということは言ってますよ
私は悪口言いますけど
他の宗教でもそれは言ってますよ
どうすれば幸福になりますか？という
題目を唱えなさいとか言ってますよ
それで商売繁盛するんだよと
今日見てきましたけど
パスなければ入れませんで
あのところには まあいろいろあります
世の中で幸福になる方法っていうのは
交通安全というお守りもあるでしょ
あれかければ事故は起こしませんと
で 火事から家を守ってくれるお守りもあるでしょうに
あれも作る人も真剣に作るし
買う人も真剣に買って
家にあちこち貼ったりはするんです
で 先に火がそちらに付いちゃって
家全部燃焼はするんですけど
やっぱりみんな興味あるんですよ
それは それから宗教ではなく
政治家にしたっても 経済学者にしたっても
唯物論者にしたっても
やっぱりどうすればうまく生きるのかっていうことは考えてはいるんです
いろいろ言ったりもするんです
問題は誰でも命とは何かとわかってないんだからね
あの昔 恐竜いたでしょうね
あれっていうのは恐竜の骨一部一部しか見つかりませんしね
あの骨一部見つけたらストーリー作るわ作るわ
でも恐竜は復元するんですよ
肉をつけて もう私は皮膚はどうやって決めたでしょう
これすごく不思議なんです
皮膚まで復元してできないと思いますけど
それだけじゃなくて声まで
どこまでやるのかと こんなのは
まあ私みたいな仏教の坊主にしてみれば
もうもうアホじゃないかということはありますけど
まあ俗世間にはそんなことはとても大事な研究で
どうぞ頑張ってください
それは一向に構わないんだけど
で 時々化石になった歯 1本しか見つかってないんだけど
ああ ここら辺でこんな形の
こんなこんなの なんだらかんだらいたんでしょうと
もう絵までイメージの絵まで出たりしていますよ
はい それで私が言いたいところは
それでもマチな方なんですよ
全く合ってないかもしれませんよ
恐竜の皮膚とかなんとかとか
それ作ったっても それと違うでしょうね
おそらくわからないんです
で なんで骨がこんな形
これはこうではない こうではないかと言いますけど
もしかすると違うかもしれません
それでも首の骨とか見つかっちゃうと
それから考えて考えて
妄想をやりたい放題妄想して
この動物は声を出すならばこうなるんではないかとシミュレーションはするんです
しかし 知ったものじゃないんです
カラスの喉を調べて カラスはカーッと鳴くんだと
どうやって知るんですかね
どんな鳥の口も同じですよ
美しいメロディで鳴く鳥もいますけど
喉はほとんど同じなんです
だから それでも私はそれがマチな方
なぜならば ほんのちょっとでも参考になるものがあるんです
例えば太ももの方での骨1本見つかる
それでイメージを膨らまして体格を考えたりする
何かあるんですよ 思考開発
組み立てていくために
ほんのちょっとのポイント
だからもうまるっきり合ってなくても
まあ別にしょうがないんですよ
ほんのわずかな証拠あるんだから
宇宙研究者と同じなんですよ
ほんのわずかななんとかの信号の変更な変化なんですよ
それにストーリー作るは作るは作るは
しかし 宇宙科学やら恐竜の研究やらやる人々にしても
何かみじんでもデータがあるんです
しかし どう生きれば幸福になるのかということを考えて
こうしましょう ああしましょうと言う人々には
命とは何かというデータはみじっもないんです
ゼロです だからうわごとにすぎないと私は言ってるんです
生きることに楽しみがある
幸福があると前提として決めている
みんな生きることは楽しいに決まっている
生きることは幸福である
それは決まっていると
遊ぶことも ご飯を食べることも
旅行も家族も楽しいんです
人間にとっては 皆に認められること
褒められること 好かれることは楽しいんです
まあ異論ないでしょう
それは楽しいんです そのために生きているんです
楽しいんだから生きているんですよ
だから褒められると調子に乗っちゃって
子供なんかはもう何でもやるでしょ
褒めてあげたら ちょっとちょっと大げさに褒めてあげる
何でもやる だから褒められる
楽しいんですよ だから皆さんはその手段を使っているでしょうに
私もやっぱり人がなんか仕事をする気がなくなっちゃって
もう疲れ切って もう暗くなってくるともう褒めちゃいます
突然褒めるとすぐもう生き返ってきます
それって誰でも使ってる手段なんですよ
ダメだこれと言ったっても意味がないんですよ
あんたなんでこんな調子でダメでしょうとか
そういうだ なおさらダメになっちゃいますね
そういうことで褒められると楽しいし
だから頑張って生きてるんです
認められると楽しいし
他人に好かれると楽しいし
それで頑張った 頑張っちゃいます
だから この楽しみも そのために生きるということにもなるんです
一つは死なないということ
それは無意識にあるんだから
あんまり派手に毎日思い出すということはしません
私は死なないためにご飯を食べているんだとか
誰も思ってないんです
私は死なないために呼吸しているんだとかね
しかし それは事実ですよ
もし誰か口を閉めちゃうと
こんなことやったら死にますよ
死ぬでしょうと その時思い出すんです
生まれて初めて そういうことだから
それは基本的にあの記録しているプログラムで
それは私たちはもう置いといて
あれは消せません ちょっと消せる簡単なプログラムできてるんです
生きること楽しいと そういうことで
楽しみのために生きているということになります
うまくいってる人は何のために生きるのか疑問を持たないんですよ
楽しく生きる それはうまくいってる
だったら 何のために生きるのかということは疑問が生まれません
失敗者の質問 疑問です
落ち込んで生きる力が失った人を
生きていればいくらでも良いこと
楽しいことたくさんあるから頑張ってと励ますんですよ
ひどい励まし方なんです
だから皆様 落ち込んでいる人を励ましてもうまくいかないでしょ
私に任せてください  1 分で治りますからね
これ励ます励まし方は変ですね
何かあるんだから 生きていれば何か楽しいことあるんだから
落ち込まなくても もう自殺願望を持たなくてもと言ったってもね
初めから敗者ですからね
敗北者だからね また頑張るのという気持ちになるんですよ
やってみたんだけどと
40歳になるまで一歩も動くいかなかったと
だから今はもうとにかく自殺したいと
まあまあ そんなこと言わないで
生きていれば何かいいことあるんだからとかね
楽しいことあるんだと励ましますけど
うまくいかない そんなのはね
生きることに意味がないという人は変人です
これで世間の価値観でしょうね
今思って 世間の価値観というリストを書いています
世間は生きることに何の意味がない
あんな人 ちょっとおかしい
生きること楽しいなのに
酒飲むことすごい楽しいなのに
パチンコあれむっちゃ楽しいんだよと
という人はお前変だと言うんです ４
時間パチンコやって帰ってる人に友達があって
友達が私はね 生きることって何なのかと
意味があるのかと思っています
あのね お前ちょっと頭がおかしくない？と言うんです
本人何やったかとパチンコやって帰ってると
あれってすごい意味があるんですかね
結局は だから楽しみに
なんて言います？病みつきになっちゃって
あの生きる意味があるか否かは調べません
だから生きることって何？という質問をする
子供は質問しますよ よく
子供は敗者ではないんですよ
だから私はその質問を子供が聞く場合は
ものすごい違う答え出すんです
大人に言いません かなり知恵の高い知恵の答え出すんです
大人がその質問をすると
こういう風にもうクタクタ
もうからかわれるんです
できるだけ金を儲けて贅沢に生きようと
やみくもに頑張る人は
明るくて活発で正常な人ですね
そういうふうに世界は思っているんです
異論はないでしょう おそらく
また 世間の価値観続きます
知識を得ること 良い仕事が見つかること
金が儲かること 社会的な立場を築くこと
有名になること 贅沢をすること
遊ぶことなどは生きる目的なんです
それも世間論だから 皆様にそれほど難しくないと思います
皆様 変人かどうか分かりませんだけど
普通常識 社会世間人だったら当たり前やと思うはずなんです
誰でも大体そういう目的で生きています
といっても 世界は無常です
認めてくはない事実です
世界は無常です 命は無常です
それは否定します みんな却下しますと
勝手にします しなさいと
私は認めませんと 無常ということ
却下しますという立場も世間の立場なんです
財産を集めても 仕事があっても
家族がいてもいても亡くなる恐れがあるんですよ
我々は無常は却下しますけど
無常なんですよ 事実は
だから金を貯めて貯めていってもなくなるんですよ
株なんかに奥たんぎで金入れてあってもね
1日2日で跡形もなく消えるんです
あ 家族がいるんだとかね
すごい悲しい どういうこと起こるでしょ？子供
子供と楽しく生活しているのに
子供が出て行ったら帰ってこない
それで命が終わったと
そういうことっていうのは
もういつでもあることでしょうね
もう昨日のニュースかなね
子供が亡くなった いなくなったって警察にね
まあ届け出して で その逮捕したのは子供を殺した
遺体放棄したという罪でね
まあまあ 殺したかって
まだ解剖してないんだから言ってなかったんですけど
母親と母親が付き合ってる男2人を警察に届け出したのはその人々なんですけど
子供がいなくなりましたと
だからまあそういうことってある
まああちらは殺したかもしれませんだからね
それではなくて 自分の大事な子供が誰かに誘拐されたり殺されたりというケースも結構あるでしょうに
だから家族がいるんだ
我が輩は安全だと ないんです
仕事があるんだ だからお前ら心配することは何もないんだと家族に言えませんよ
子供がいろいろな勉強に挑戦したい
しかし 金がかかる 子供は外国に行ってちょこちょこといろんなことをもう学びたいと
すると父親と母親がもうもう君が勉強したいことをちゃんとやってください
でもお父さん もうそんなに金がない
ああ それは気にすることはない
もうなんとか安心 もう安心しなさいと
仕事があるんだから そんなこと言えたもんじゃないんですよ
無常なんですよ ですから
我々は楽しみを目指して生きようとすると
同時に恐怖感というものが生まれてくるんです
で 金もうけ 儲かる生き方をする
金儲かる 楽しいんですよ
もっと成功 もっとやります
もっとやります やっちゃいますけど
同時に全部壊れていくかもしれませんという恐怖感が出てきます
有名人であっても名誉が消えることもあります
あまり具体的な例を言わなくても
今知っているでしょうに
ちょっとしたことを大したことじゃないんでしょうに
若者だから 注意することでもなんでもないんです
なのに その人の名誉は全部消されるという
残酷でしょ 何一つも保証はないんですよ
人生の中で それは認めないんです
またそれも ですから どこまででも財産を貯める
立場を確保するということになって
欲にキリがない人になるんです
我々はこの自然の流れでキリのない
限りのない欲の人間になってますよ
そのからくり それなんです
10万円儲かって もうこれやばいんですよ
明日仕事なくなるかもしれません
だから明日仕事ある だったらもっと 10万円
儲かっちゃうんです 明後日も明後日も
もう十分ですよ そんなこと言ったって
どうなるかわからないでしょうと
だから どんな人間にもこの生きることに保証がないんですよ
楽しく生きられるという保証がないんです
あなたなら絶対心臓発作は起こしませんとか
じゃあ保証ある？あなたなら絶対認知症にはなりませんとか
がんにはかかりませんとか
事故は起こしませんとか
知ったもんじゃないんですよ
だから我々は必死で この幸福のために
楽しみのために 財産などなど
財産やら名誉やら いろんなものは貯める
貯める 貯める 貯める いくら貯めたらいいかというと
これはないんです だから限りのない欲
リミットのない欲という精神病気が生まれているんです
その病気を作ったのは
保証がないということは否定しただからなんです
すべて無常ということは否定したんだからなんです
限りのない欲と執着について
否定している無常は事実なので
無常の流れに流されることは避けられないんです
誰でも無常の流れ流れに流されるんです
しかし 何でもかんでも確保したいんですよ
流されているのに 安定させたいんです
この無理で現実不可能な現実実現不可能な現実的でない希望は
恐怖感 不安感 悩み 苦しみなどを作り出します
だから 今日のお話 理解できれば
お釈迦様の心の中を読んだことになります
お釈迦様はこういうふうに説法しないんです
もっとわかりやすく しかし
お釈迦様はこういうふうな思考なんです
なんでこれが生まれるのかとかね
だから説法するとき 突然恐怖感があるでしょ？じゃああんた
もうそれは死にたくないと思っているんだからでしょというふうな感じで持っていくだけ
どうせ死ぬんだから諦めなさい
例えば あるお母さんがね
子供が亡くなっちゃって
ものすごい精神的におかしくなっちゃって
お釈迦様のところに来る
頭いかれてるんですよ
あと あのね あんたすごいひどいショック受けてるでしょうと
今頭おかしくなってるでしょうと言ったら
ああ まあその通りです
あれはね あんたの亡くなった子供に対してって
あんたすごい愛着だからですね
はいはい その通りですと
まあでも愛着があってもね
あなたを助けてくれてないね
子供は あんた苦しんでるだけですよと
あんた何も得てないんだと
ただ死んだ子供のために頭いかれただけで
だからそんなのどうでもいいでしょ
あなたのためにならん
言うとみんなホッとするんですよ
お釈迦様の言葉だから
ジキジキ聞くんだから
それでもう悟りに達しますよ
それから出家したりして
しかし 生命の法則として
お釈迦様はそういうふうに発見していったんです
これで最終的ではなくて
今のステージになってくると
我々には悩みがあるわ
苦しみがあるわ 恐怖感があるわ
これ 初めは生きることを楽しいということで始めたでしょうに
生きることは本当に楽しいと始まったのに
褒めと褒められると楽しいし
認められると楽しいし
好かれると楽しいし 金が入ってくると楽しいし
子供が生まれてくると楽しいし
だったら楽しいだけで終わるはずなんでしょうに
次 我々は無常を否定していますから
この楽しいものは確保しておきましょうと
頑張るんです あれ 無理です
確保しても消えるんだから
とにかくありったけのものを確保しておきますと
少々消えてもまだ残るという状態までということで
無限な欲が限りのない欲が生まれてくる
次 何でも確保しようということは無理だと
消えると 例えば億万長者がもう 1週間以内で倒産して
お金がない人になると
かなり厳しいと思いますよ
不安感 悩み 苦しみが生まれてきます
恐怖 不安 恐怖 不安を感じると
さらに確保のために頑張る
そこでまた失敗するんです
それは世間の生き方なんですよ
恐怖感を感じたり お金がなくなるかも
仕事がクビになるかもということを感じると
徹底的に頑張っちゃうんです
仕事を確保しようと このように限りのない欲
生きることに対する強烈な執着
不安 恐怖感という恐ろしい渦巻きに巻き込まれても
巻き込まれてもがきながら生きることは世間の生き方です
世間はもがきながら生きているんです
すべての生命はどうったことないんです
はい これで一つのセクションが終わります